whether or not you can recognize what
something is doesn't change what it is I
can't tell if it's gold or pyrite
doesn't change it from gold or pyrite
if there is a human life and you're like
well I can't tell if it's human or not
that's like saying someone who's got a
disfigurement may not be human no
they're human if it appears to be
something you can kind of play like it
is like if somebody because you don't
know what it is doesn't change what it
is
I agree with that but if someone comes
up to you a hologram points a gun to
your head and you think it's real you're
gonna probably piss yourself something
real is not the same as whether or not
it is real think of it yeah but your
body will react as if it is but
perception is immaterial to the question
of objectivity I don't know because
right you know IVF you're creating new
embryos in a Petri dish to implant them
in a woman down the line right but my
big aha moment is when I have achieved
sperm egg fusion and I have all these
embryos now right and now I have all
these little embryos that I can then go
on and plant and they'll continue to
develop into ultimately some of them we
hope a full-term baby